consumer culture is seductive but it
also brings rewards it feels good it's
interesting you know there's a lot of
things that we really love about it
electricity yeah I love technology I'm
an early adopter of everything so the
question then becomes you know how do
you engage with consumer culture without
losing your culture without losing
control of your culture
so there's possibilities that
globalization creates who create and
protect localities and you know my wife
and I have been really involved in in
Belize which is trying to get indigenous
people at some rights over the ruins of
their ancestors and so that they're not
just being exploited by tourists to
enrich tour guides and cruise companies
and then they invited her to the village
and took her out the showed her this
ruin that they had been protecting for
the last hundred and fifty years with a
like the last unlooted pyramid in Belize
and they said you know we want you to
come here and work with the community to
develop this as a tourist site in our
wildlife sanctuary so that it will be a
continuing source of knowledge and
income for the community and in the
process we want you to train our people
to be archaeologists and to be tour
guides so if you want to keep things
local and you want to keep on in control
you really have to be careful about
being drawn out into into turning it
into a commodity you know I think in
every civilization food has become part
of class it's become part of how people
differentiate different classes from
each other and it's also become a form
of entertainment
yeah but lately you know they've
excavated some that were destroyed by
earthquakes and it turns out almost all
the rooms were used to store the pottery
used to serve feasts Wow and that really
what these things were were places where
large groups of people came together and
ate together yeah so you know we can
tell what people ate we can tell how
much seafood they were getting in their
diet from looking at different isotope
signatures in the bone Wow we can now
get residue from the edges of stone
tools so we can tell that they were
cutting with it that's crazy right
because like the fat from an animal
actually bonds with the silica in the in
the tool and I think as archaeology
progresses we're gonna find out that
there's a close relationship between
politics and hunger yeah I think what
archaeology is going to be able to show
us is what kinds of things produce such
a radical kind of inequality that some
people are willing to stand around
eating while other people in front of
them are dying of starvation
yeah someone's opinion me contradict
yours
why is my friend Alan it's all about
your perspective
who are we and what is the nature of
this reality what's up everyone welcome
to simulation I'm your host Don Sakia we
are still on site at the American
Anthropological Association Annual
Meeting in Vancouver British Columbia
this is our second partnership with them
we are now gonna be talking about
consumer culture food archeology and so
much more we have dr. Richard wolf
joining us on the show hi Rick hi thanks
for inviting me thanks for coming on the
program it was a great synergy that this
ended up coming together yeah it was
kind of accidental but sometimes
accidents lead in the best directions
yes yes as as this reality likes to
piece things together and for reasons
that are yet to be discovered
no I know I'm so excited for this
episode Rich's Rick's background so
interesting he spent 31 years professing
at the University of Indiana he's the
director of the opening at the plot
anthropology Institute and I really want
to jump into things Rick we love talking
about these like very first principles
questions to start do you think that
we're really all one I think we're one
in this sense that we owned the planet
in common and all of the resources
belong to all of us and I don't I think
it's kind of a failure of our
spirituality nationalism and other kinds
of identity that keeps us from
recognizing that and that goes right to
the issue of climate change because some
people are using up a lot more oxygen
and emitting a lot more carbon dioxide
than other people and if you think about
the atmosphere as common property
something that belongs to all of us
equally you've got to recognize that we
need to control
who gets to pollute basically and right
now
it seems to be based on how much money
you've got so I'm working with some
investigative journalists right now
we're trying to put together the carbon
footprint of billionaires yeah to get a
sense of just how much more of the
Earth's common resources are going to
individuals who have like 9 yachts and
yeah fleets of airplanes that's right so
it's kind of hard to tell someone that
they have to change their diet and they
eat less meat in order to save the
climate when you've got someone who's
gallivanting around the world in a
private helicopter and private jet yeah
I really like this way that you took it
which is that we are one we have this
planet with the other 10 million species
on it we have to wake up and enlighten
ourselves to that realization that we
are all interconnected then we do
analyses of when you put it into a
hierarchy of wealth you have these 1500
billionaires at the top how many of them
have ever felt in any sort of
enlightenment of unconditional love
before and then furthermore where are
the resources that are being allocated
to these additional boats planes cars
materialistic possessions or to aim to
be uplifting those 50% of people that
earn less than 2 dollars and 50 cents a
dates so that their gifts can be
actualized these are our brothers and
sisters not others these are one this is
one and I like the analysis there and
also if you look at a hierarchy in a
different way in terms of those that are
spiritually enlightened at the top it's
like the Dalai Lama and stuff like that
well why can't we take their most first
principles and apply them to the world
rather than have the top of the wealthy
be plutocrats governing the planet I
really like that point there and I want
to ask the next question which is do you
think that the root of all of the
symptoms the the downstream symptoms is
that we have these feelings of you being
separate
and us not feeling the dear
interconnectedness with ourselves and
all the other species in the environment
yeah I agree I think you know to some
extent wealth enables the rich to live
separately and to act as if there are
different species you know I always
remember that scene where George Bush
goes to the grocery store and he's never
seen a scanner before because he's never
been in a grocery store because he's
always had people shopping for him and
you know it tells you just how
incredibly separate their world has
become and you'd like to think that it
it's nationalism but actually there's
super-rich people in every country the
poorest countries have some of the
richest people so I think it's kind of
lack of visibility we can't see each
other we can't hear each other we can't
understand each other's motives and
ideas and that means we can't empathize
and we can't put ourselves in the place
of another person which is one reason I
value anthropology so tremendously as a
career and as a way of thinking about
the world because it requires you to put
yourself in somebody else's place
yeah and to really strive to understand
the world as that person sees it yeah
and you know I've met amazing people who
are electricians plumbers farmers tour
guides people who you know if I was just
hanging around with people like me at a
university I would never meet these
people I would never know what their
lives are like and just having that
experience you know I wish all of our
students at the universities could just
go live in a poor family for a few
months and learn what it's like yeah
this is a also a really profound point
which is this very multidisciplinary
study of anthropology forces you to get
behind
the true deepest empathetic visceral
perspective of other people's
moment-to-moment existence and if you do
things like get young children to to
pass weeks or months living in places in
the world of lower socioeconomic status
less access to electricity healthcare
education etc there's that deeper shrew
experience of wisdom that then kicks in
of oh my goodness it is so important for
us to actualize all of our gifts I like
that a lot isn't what we're talking
about right now regarding the sheer
complexity of this reality at this exact
moment where we have to rise to this
challenge to figure out how to best move
forward is that the purpose of this all
being made well I think that one's
beyond my competence in in the sense
that the search for purpose is also a
search inside yourself and it always is
and you know I think radical doubt is
probably the best that we can manage at
any time and that is admitting what we
don't know and don't understand and kind
of coming from a humble position that
recognizes that you know the complexity
of the world in the universe is so great
and it's so vast the size of the
universe is so great that you know we
have to recognize that in time our era
is going to end up being like an inch
thick you know our entire world today
will be gone someday you know and just
getting to the moon the closest body is
just an incredibly difficult thing for
us so recognizing how small you are and
how limited our ability to understand
the world is you know I guess I was
naive when I went into anthropology
thinking that by this time in my life I
would have a better understanding of the
the world works and you know I think I
understand more but I also understand
more about what I don't know and and I'm
constantly finding the world mysterious
in in strange in different ways in fact
I find my own country the United States
much harder to understand than a lot of
other places where I've been and where
I've worked where as an outsider I have
a different perspective and when I can
compare that to what insiders are
thinking and saying it gives you a
different it gives you what in kind of
vision studies is called parallax
exactly it's like the ability to see
depth because you can see it from two
different directions that's the same
time that's right that's why I think
it's really urgent ly important to get
foreign anthropologists and sociologists
to come and study us here in the United
States I love this point because you
know these are the people who can give
us that parallax that's right and can
give us another point of view so that
you know we can start thinking about
things in a different way rather than
just kind of following the same ruts
interesting so anthropologists going and
studying as Outsiders of those nations
can go to those nations study them those
people can come study us I really like
that idea in gaining unique insights
with that parallax is yeah it's crucial
for understanding how to best move
forward to there's a little marketing
that I want to do which is that the open
anthropology foundation which is a 501 C
3 non-profit our goal is to raise enough
money to endow a grant that will bring a
four installer to study the United
States as for a year
that's excellent that's just $100,000 or
so I'm like well actually
we're working with the wintergreen
foundation for anthropological research
which has been giving research grants
for years and years to anthropologists
and archaeologists and they funded my
fieldwork twice mm-hmm and in order to
fund an annual grant the endowment needs
to be half a million dollars absolutely
for one scholar each year each year Yeah
right
so in perpetuity yeah and to be a
multi-year project yeah yeah and that's
where we've kind of my wife and I she's
also an anthropologist and pi burn we've
decided to basically our our daughter is
doing fine so we've basically agreed
that most of our wealth when we die is
going to go into this foundation yeah
but we're also kind of actively raising
money and we want to build it as fast as
we can I love it the open anthropology
foundation which has the open
anthropology Institute within yeah yeah
a 501 C 3 the links in the bio below to
that to those that may be interested in
funding this because this is brilliant
if we can get an apology to come and
study us too for us to better understand
us that's that's huge yeah I love that
I sure have trouble I need another point
of view because I'm baffled most of the
time yeah yeah actually this is a big
big insight out in Silicon Valley as
well as we have leaders saying things
like if I'm starting a company the one
rule of the CEO of that company is that
they have never worked in the industry
before yeah and I think that's a really
profound statement it's like no I don't
want someone that's worked in biotech
for 20 years to be the biotech CEO I
want someone that's come never worked in
the industry and so that style of an
outsider's perspective on is critical in
many ways so this is a really cool idea
and well we might get to a little bit
more of the whole banan topology
Foundation Institute stuff in a bit but
this is a good start on it so 31 years
professing at the University of Indiana
I mean there's been so much research
that has happened but you kind of gave
me this first one on
focus on consumer culture that was so
interesting so is this kind of like as
urbanization and globalization has
happened more wealth has accrued people
have decided to move further away from
like farming and agrarian style habits
to urban environments where houses are
bought cars are bought cetera stuff yes
yeah
after a short career in archaeology I
went to Southern Belize in 1976 and
there are two indigenous Mayan groups
that live in southern Belize and I ended
up spending a year living in three
different villages learning as much of
the language as I could and it was just
at this moment when young people were
starting to think that you know farming
it was not really a way of life that was
going to support them into the future
you know they were growing rice and
getting fifteen cents a pound for it and
it it's just their parents couldn't
afford school and couldn't afford
clothes and couldn't afford medical care
and and so young people were starting to
do something that had previously
previously been unthinkable leave the
community and get a paying job and give
up kind of all of the great things that
come with belonging to a community and
I've been kind of working on and off
with that group of people ever since and
it's turned into a struggle for control
of their own land so for the last 20
years I've been an expert witness in
court and trying to kind of not wanting
to run anything or take authority or act
in a kind of guiding way but to find out
what people want and do the best I can
to facilitate it happening
when it comes to things like affidavits
and court cases and I I think the the
happiest moment I've had in my and most
rewarding moment in my career was being
invited by the Maya leaders Alliance to
a meeting where they they wanted me and
other anthropologists to advise them
yeah and it's you know after a lifetime
of going places and trying to convince
people to talk to you to have them in
the driver's seat and it was like the
fulfillment of the way I thought
anthropology should be from the very
beginning oh wow that's such a mutually
beautiful yeah relationship it's with
the words here sometimes they're
mentioned like information extraction
which is not the way you want to do it
rather this may we please come and and
and become completely immersed in your
beautiful culture and rituals and
practices and learn from you and and
then as we do that can we somehow
provide you with any help that you may
need and and then like you said getting
invited back and yeah this is that's
that is a beautiful way to do that was
the deal that we made when I when I
started doing research in 1976 and then
living there and 78 they said you know
well if we're helping you get your
doctorate degree and right you're gonna
write a book about us you're taking all
these pictures we want you to give
something back and we don't know what
that's going to be but in the future
we're gonna call on you and we're gonna
expect you to to help us yeah and I took
that really seriously and that's always
been like my number one priority yeah so
like I was in Kazakhstan and they told
me I had to be testifying in the Supreme
Court the next day early in the morning
so basically I I flew for 26 hours and
kind of ran down the street and into the
courtroom to testify goodness
but you know that's I think that's how
serious when you make a commitment to
people that's you know that's what
you're going to do yeah wow this is uh
that's a real that's heart right there
yeah
whoa okay so was the study of this the
transition to the consumer cultures
observing kind of what was going on in
beliefs and in different places yeah
yeah so what was that yeah what was that
like the interesting thing was that
there was no anthropology of consumer
culture until the 1980s
you know because anthropologists had
always been trying to get to the real
stuff the way it used to be before
people started you know wearing modern
clothes or learning English or going to
college and by the time I started
working in Belize there were there was
at least one Belize an anthropologist
there were a lot of very well educated
deletions and the there was no way to
pretend that I was gonna be studying the
way it once was
as if that was like the true culture
frozen in time to go into an
encyclopedia somewhere you know as the
catchy Maya the mopin Maya know you know
these people have always been changing
and the kind of change that they were
going through at the time is something
that we've seen all over the planet and
that is consumer culture is seductive
but it also brings rewards it feels good
it's interesting you know there's a lot
of things that we really love about it
electricity yeah yeah yeah I love
technology
I'm an early adopter of everything I'm
driving an electric car you know it's
it's it's endlessly entertaining and
using and so to go somewhere else and
say oh you guys you should stay the way
you are so that I can study you well I'm
kind of jetting back and forth and using
my my phone to access the Internet
so the question then becomes you know
how do you engage with consumer culture
without losing your culture without
losing control of your culture and at
the time I started doing this research
thinking of yourself as an ethnic group
in a multi-ethnic country was really the
way that you created and protected
something of your own and it gave you
kind of the power to approach technology
and education and all these institutions
from a situation of where you had some
strengths rather than where you're just
a victim victim victim and Belizeans
crafted their own version of consumer
culture and I was just really lucky to
be there in the country in the early 80s
when television came to the country I
was working there at the time for the US
Agency for International Development I
was there when the whole country became
Chicago Cubs fans yeah what and I was
there for the opening of the first
Billie Jean restaurant in Belize at a
time when the whole country was wrapped
up in the Miss Belize pageant and I'm a
Miss Carrie funa pageant and Miss
panamericana and like every town in
every village and every ethnic group was
having a beauty pageant and at first you
know I thought this was just you know
sexist stuff I didn't really want to go
to but when I started to listen to what
people are telling me it turned out that
this is where people were really working
out what being believed
was or what being Garifuna or what being
Hispanic Maya or Yucatec oh we're you
know what our clothes were what kinds of
music are important for us to conserve
what kinds of performances so it was
kind of a stage for thinking about the
nation and locality and all of the other
segments of society so I kind of
reluctantly got dragged into studying
beauty pageants but at the same time
they were also inventing Billie Jean
food and this was happening in Chicago
mostly initially among Billie Jean
migrants to Chicago who found themselves
like everybody thinking there were
Jamaicans and they don't like thought of
this Jamaican so there was a pollution
restaurant ablution bar in New York and
those people were moving back and forth
and then you know in the 90s we had this
flood of tourism as well and food became
part of the tourist industry and the
tourist experience so that I found that
was just really an interesting time to
be there and I was lucky to be there to
see a lot of it happen whoa yeah I
really appreciated how you you gave us
this this just like trajectory of the
slow but steady technology becoming more
and more a part of people's cultures and
then also doing things like having a
beauty pageant that seems like it's such
a like Oh like yeah like something
around like appreciating the aesthetics
of beauty but to but to see it a ask
something where different cultures can
express their themselves and that we can
see those distinct expressions viewing
it in that light is really nice and and
it's it's also like you're giving this
example just
when you when you are benign so you move
you know there's me being able to like
go to Chicago or you know and see these
like kind of like populations my
migrating starting businesses in those
areas I mean this is the becoming more
of a melting pot and becoming more open
to what ibly Genevan is and that's in a
sense that's but that's very important
you gave you kind of started leading us
a little bit into I think you said like
the you know how do you do the process
of of enjoying what technology enables
with creativity with health and wellness
education what you're trying to do right
here exactly yeah yeah how do we do this
but then how do we not yeah you have it
like the business plans of the attention
economy right and mental issues so right
so there's always this dichotomous and
finding what we believe is the best and
taking that forth and dropping the
archaic things that are not so great and
the way that technology actually affects
the indigenous cultures as well and
tourism how that affects it yeah and you
know it's victimology is easy you know
it's always easy to say well you know
it's social media destroying the culture
ruining the experience of childhood
whatever you know they said the same
thing about television in the 1980s you
know both the right and the left were
really concerned that TV was going to
destroy local culture and instead you
know they developed indigenous
television you know and there's fabulous
video made in Belize about the country
and you can watch the news every night
and and you know they kind of turned it
in a direction where it really creates
community by bringing people in Chicago
and Los Angeles into the same setting
that that there
Elysian family is in so there's
possibilities that globalization creates
to create and protect locality is and
you know how as you know these things
are tools there the technology doesn't
determine completely what you do with it
and it's always possible to turn things
around and kind of subvert the dominant
paradigm and or to take the tools of the
powerful and turn them around and find
other ways to use them so the diaspora
of a culture can tune in the the
television programming and observe how
its culture is evolving from from afar
and keep a stronger community tie thanks
to that globalization in urbanization
which is quite interesting technology
fication yeah yeah for me the real
turning point the way I thought about
things was in 1976 the Triple A meetings
were in LA and LA has a huge billion
community and there was a billion
anthropologist Joe Palacio living in LA
at the time and we decided we were going
to have a session at that purple area
where we would invite the believes
community to come in and tell
anthropologists what they wanted to know
about their country and to kind of give
us some direction about what they saw is
the most interesting and important
issues and there were like 200 people
there several with video cameras because
they plan to send the record of this
conversation back to their relatives in
Belize and so you know it kind of
instantly made me aware that even if we
think of ourselves as being you know
isolated in an ivory tower were not in
any way were connected in lots of
different ways
you know the personal is political and
for my generation having an egalitarian
marriage you know was an act of radical
imagination and really difficult
practice you know because you've got to
unlearn everything that you learned from
your parents about gender roles and it
can be full of conflict and you know
sometimes you need some tough lessons to
learn some important things it's kind of
like this young consciousness that's
moving with Millennials and Gen Z into
awareness of the biosphere and all the
other species and the way that then
throughout the scene is actually
affecting biodiversity and just
sustainability ecology in general
younger consciousness also is so
literate with technology and and it's in
in many ways it's interesting thinking
about how to have older consciousness
sort of let let Google go of their grip
on the economic machinery and let the
young ones come in Architects world yeah
yeah I get the anti boomer message even
though I'm kind of a tail and boomer
myself you know I can't really say that
my generation has been a particularly
good job of running things on the other
hand you know I think some of us really
were trying to make radical change from
the time we were teenagers you can look
at how in the 1960s psychedelics
consciousness movement just got squashed
yeah what turned into consumer culture
you know I turned into fashion items
bell-bottom pants and fringes and you
know for those of us who really felt
like we wanted to see a radical change
in the world it was like you know seeing
your sacred place turned into a tourist
attraction
yeah and and that's something that my
wife and I have been really involved in
in Belize which is trying to get
indigenous people some rights over the
ruins of their ancestors yeah and so
that they're not just being exploited by
tourists to enrich tour guides and
cruise companies yeah to get the
indigenous the rights of the land yeah
yeah versus only profiteering on the
tourism yeah that's so interesting so
that's actually probably a macro level
phenomenon that's happening with
indigenous lands around the world and in
museums you know and even anthropology
departments when I became department
chair in 1980 it I found that we had
thousands of Native American skeletons
in boxes in our building and elsewhere
on campus that were being used for
studies but not studies that were in any
way connected to the concerns of the
indigenous people who dissented from
those bones so finally over the last ten
years the university has kind of stepped
up and now the university has been has
pretty good relations with more than 30
Native American tribes and we've been
working out ways of repatriating and
giving those ancestors back in a way
that is honorable and respectful and I
see that I don't think the people who
wrote the Native American graves and
repatriation act in the 1970s knew what
it really was going to do but what it
did was to empower Native people in a
way that they really needed and that is
to control their the artifacts of their
culture yes you know your soul enters
important objects and that's something I
learned in studying consumer culture the
people developed like love relationship
yes with their things 150 times a day is
when we're grabbing the device yeah and
you know put it away for a day and you
find out just how much it's a part of
your body it has become yes and so you
know if we're going to really respect
people that means given the Elgin
marbles back to the Greeks and emptying
out a lot of treasure firm Western
museums yeah and it's not like
indigenous people just want to bury it
now that they have control they can come
to scientists until scientists what they
want to know and it can be a harmonious
love based relationship rather than an
extractive one where it becomes a
scientist anthropologist working more
closely together with different cultures
around the world yeah that that's a
really good that's a really good point
where they can actually start helping
guide anthropologist and scientist
towards the specific ways of
understanding their lineages and exactly
that's so interesting but I was doing
fieldwork in a Creole village in central
Belize in 1990 and I told him my wife
was an archaeologist and she we were
living not too far away she was
commuting out to her or to her site
every day because we had a one-year-old
baby and the village it turned out went
the village chairman went to the library
in the capital city and looked up her
name and learned something about her and
then they invited her to the village and
took her out and showed her this ruin
that they had been protecting for the
last hundred and fifty years with a like
the last unlooted pyramid in Belize and
they said you know we want you to come
here and work with the community to
develop this as a tourist site in our
wildlife sanctuary
so that it will be a continuing source
of knowledge and income for the
community and in the process we want you
to train our people to be archaeologists
and to be tour guides Wow and she spent
the next 15 years pretty much working at
that site we couldn't get the Belize
government to ever pay for a watchman or
somebody to guarantee to keep the place
intact because the village kind of voted
the wrong way in a couple of national
elections so we paid for a watchman to
stay out at the site ourselves free you
know years and years yeah but it was it
kind of turned her whole idea of what
archaeology was around so you know now
Anna's been around the world promoting
community-based archaeology where you
know people are motivated about the past
they want to know about their ancestors
they're just not they're just not
interested in having foreigners come and
take it away the community base the
harmonic style of anthropology you
mentioned your next study being like
some beauty pageants a little bit
earlier is there more there that can
kind of awaken us yeah what else can
awaken us to what exactly is this beauty
pageants well you know I think what
we've seen is in beauty pageants even at
the level of a place like Belize a lot
of organizations start is volunteerism
you know they come out of community
efforts they get organized as volunteer
groups I like to use the example in this
country of double dutch jump rope which
was you know something kids played on
the playground mostly african-american
kids played on the playground but just
the same way that beauty pageants over
time became more and more structure
and all these kind of arbitrary
divisions started to appear like if you
were under 17 it was you were Miss
Belize and then there was over 25 for
mrs. Belize and the even though the
Belize ins wanted it to be about much
more than physical beauty if you wanted
to get into Miss Panamericana you have
to have a national costume you have to
hire someone from Texas who isn't a
professional advisor of beauty pageant
contestants same thing happened with
double-dutch two leagues formed
volunteerism by parents in inner-city
neighborhoods trying to get their kids
interested in something that would
occupy them and competitive but also
expressive and artistic and fun well you
know ten years later you've got
professional double-dutch coaches you
have like a-holes a whole structure
that's built so that now we have two
national leagues they have a season they
have finals they have championships and
it's kind of falling into a format that
we're all pretty much familiar with
which takes it out of the community
takes it out of popular control and
freezes it with a set of rules so it
becomes a professional kind of
enterprise this happens with volunteer
groups it happens with coops it happens
with you know drama groups it happens
over and over again and you know you
really have to struggle to keep
organizations like you want you on an
outside grant when you got a write a
proposal you have to have membership you
have to count your members so if you
want to keep things local and you want
to keep on in control you really have to
be careful
about you know being drawn out into into
turning it into a commodity and
basically now there's like training
camps and there's double dutch parents
who do nothing but travel around all
around the country to different you know
so as though that these in these early
days of some sort of a sport or activity
that people find interesting is
practiced and developed locally there's
maybe more of like there's more creative
combinatorial prophecies and spirit but
then when it tries to go up spread onto
it like the national and international
level it becomes rules and then exactly
which creates no discipline
consumeristic kind of culture around it
as well a little yeah discipline yeah
but it's that that that's interesting as
long as it also I guess also enables
though people to try and add and
creatively augment what those
infrastructures are work to keep
something like you know Cub Scouts alive
as a local or you know junior local
leagues little league I was in a little
league when I was a kid
there was no discipline we had no
uniforms you know I'm sure now it's
become a lot more formalized but it's
like a Little League World Series yeah
yeah now it's become like part of this
hierarchy yeah and we don't really need
to do that to all of our popular forms
of entertainment it can be more like a
there can be like in the amateur it's
just for fun level exactly yeah you know
and it's the same thing with food you
know which is that everybody you know in
the community there's great cooks
there's all kinds of creativity going on
most of that never gets captured in a
cookbook yeah because as soon as you
start writing a cookbook you got to
figure quantities and you got to figure
out a list of ingredients but if you're
really a cook rather than a
you know well we don't have any green
bananas I'll use unripe apples instead
you know and see if that works yeah yeah
this improvisation intuition flow yeah
you taste as you go it's yeah that's
interesting yeah but you know some of my
graduate students have been studying the
way that government's set culinary
policy you know now you can nominate
your national cuisine for UNESCO
recognition as intangible cultural
property Wow and that means like you
have to pick something so my Korean
student Chi hun Kim now doctor Chi hoon
Kim studied the way the Korean
government had to decide what bibimbap
was going to be the official beibahab
yeah
wow what a hard choice given all the
variations yeah yeah every you know town
and village has its own you know way of
doing things so what you put you know
what's great about studying cuisine is
that the creativity is never completely
suppressed yeah you know there's always
pressure to kind of figure out something
new that might appeal to you given all
the food fats too so yeah this is okay
now we're adventuring into food history
and food archeology which is such an
interesting field I'm been in here lost
about 10 15 years doing this field
you're telling me about this as well
which I'll just tie in real quick just
idea that you know food fads especially
now given your talk about the consumers
that culture you know low sugar no sugar
low fat reduced fat hokey bowls yeah oh
yeah then there's a gluten freeze
there's a vegans
carnivorous hey leo hey Leo's I mean
it's yet that area is never-ending of
where things are going in terms of food
fads we do this you know anywhere now
you know this is three times a day
some people intermittently fasten only
once a day some people fast for five
days to try cow
themselves being ascetic there's all
different like interesting variations of
this we actually really recently heard
about a breatharians which I lived in
Santa Cruz when Wylie Brooks was giving
birth Aryan seminars was I had a couple
of students who were breatharians at the
science if stuff like this where it's no
water no food just the breath sunlight
etc yeah some people there's a birth
area in Congress where there's no way
people yeah yeah there's a stable and
and they there's my one of my one of our
friends was telling a story yeah I
didn't eat for 41 days and I was like
okay this is getting really interesting
people haven't ate or drank for I think
15 years or something okay but besides
that yes all these fads and then you're
giving this idea of that given a
specific region having a pick a food
country having to pick a food but given
all their regions and cities have
different variations on that food how
did they pick it yeah and this is this
is very complex grocery stores you were
teaching me about as well and they have
what was it 20 thousand new products
every year in grocery stores 98 percent
of which don't last more than a year
yeah and then they go into like a food
history museum yes this is so
interesting Green ketchup you were
talking you know those things yeah
there's work there for a while they were
trying to sell soda water in bottles
with the tapioca pearls oh yeah in them
like in bubble tea yeah one of my
students just told me bubble treat has
now made it to Japan and they see it as
an American product what because it
didn't come from Taiwan to Japan it went
from Taiwan to the US and then to Japan
so they say oh yeah this is an American
fad that we're kind of getting into now
interesting so these things circulate
globally now and some of them you know
some of them it are pretty wild
I saw Turkish Mexican food Oh
in Singapore and Kuala Lumpur
turkish mexicans turkish medicine hanbok
there's a whole chain of them now sewing
turkish mexican food which you know if
you were turkish or mexican it would
probably pretty disturbing we're
interesting or interesting you know it
depends on on whether you're defensive
or whether you're experimental yeah and
i think we all have some of both and
that's why at the same time we have this
incredible turnover we also have like
legacy foods and we have like Cheerios
have been with us forever butterfingers
bars baby ruth you know just looking at
the universe of candy there's always you
know new pop rocks and sour this or
glowing that but there's also this kind
of slower pace of things that have been
around forever and ever--
bread exactly yeah which goes in all
different types of flavor variations on
waters and bottles from different
locations on the planet there was a
funny you should mention that my most
cited paper is about bottled water
interest and that's what a panel i was
listening to here was talking about that
yeah what was that the most cited paper
on on it give us a little bit on that
well you know part of my interest in
anthropology has always been that
there's parts of the world that are
fascinating that nobody studies yes and
you know we all have a tendency to
follow the leader you know so for a
while every disc every student i'm i had
wanted to study ecotourism you know but
and i would always say well look but
there's so many other things and water
is fascinating because it's the same
stuff the US imports water and we export
water we import water from india if you
can imagine not a place known for its
purest and cleanest water we import
water for
Mexico we sell water to Mexico so we
have this global trade of and you know
water is mostly free and we pay more for
it than we pay for gasoline mm-hmm which
is supposedly a valuable thing taste
tests people can't tell the difference
between tap water and bottled water and
you know as far as health goes you're
probably better off with tap water in
most parts of the world than you are
with drinking bottled water because
there's no standards that the bottled
water has to has to live up to and
there's also a lot of injustice in you
know bottling companies taking water
away from communities and and putting it
in bottles and it's ecologically a kind
of a catastrophe as well so I guess it
was back in the nineties I just looked
at the water bottle one day and kind of
felt like if you're gonna understand
consumer culture you have to understand
how pure branding works you know because
it's the project the product is not
differentiated it just comes in
different color bottles and different
shaped bottles and there's almost always
a reference to nature mountain streams
and there's also an assurance about
technology on the back you know it's
purified it's been supervised and I
think that kind of alternation between
nature and technology is just so common
in consumer culture think about mountain
biking it's a high-tech object and it's
supposed to take you into nature so you
can experience nature so there's always
this kind of paradoxical one is behind
the other so you know when water is pure
you also want to be big through
technology
you I mean we're suspicious of the
machine and of Technology you know what
could they be putting in there maybe
we're getting residues or no from the
plastic so we then go to nature and say
oh but it comes from the mountains or
glaciers or spring or the most expensive
bottled water comes from 6,000 feet deep
in the Pacific Ocean it's brought up and
then they have to take the salt out but
that stuff sells for like $24 for 20
ounce bottle what does that brand call I
I forget the name of it you know I'm
afraid it's Japanese Japanese
interesting and they even saw it as a
concentrate Wow so it's concentrated
water that you can pour into your water
water to make your water more water
watery yeah and I figured you know if
they can sell that yeah basically they
can sell anything yeah but it has to
connect in some way to you know it's not
always an evil thing for a lot of people
drinking water is an alternative to
drinking Co of course which is probably
much worse for you oh yeah oh yes so we
deserve food archeology also
incorporates water or archeology I mean
that's a huge uh thought about field as
well you listen so many variables there
what so what's the what's the deal with
looking at food from like a macro
historical perspective
I mean immediate return hunter-gathering
had a very interconnected feeling with
nature and our environments and then
then agrarian society moved in to really
just putting the humans in a specific
area and growing the food next to the
humans and then there are so many other
interesting phenomenons that happen with
the microbiome and our dental in that
period of time and then this again you
give this all the way up to today where
you can like drink a soda product versus
a water or there's all these 25
and products coming in to grocery stores
every single year
and so many of them disappearing
afterward the amount of money that's
being spent on like R&D for that this is
no longer like mom right my mom would
give you food because she loves you and
she wants you to be healthy there's
inclusive fitness steak holding here now
big food doesn't give us about you they
want to make money right and so then
there's no inclusive steak holding there
and so this is a completely different
culture and they want to give you the
optimum combination of fat sugar and
salt you know because those things are
cheap and it turns out people love them
addictive well they're you know at one
time in our evolution the taste for salt
the taste for fat and the taste for
sweet were important they were here you
know and to some extent what advertising
and consumer culture does is it
parasitizes on our bodies takes the
potentials that we have and commodify
something turns them into a hot button
but there's also like evolutionarily
we're designed to try new stuff we're
always trying new stuff that's how we
learn to eat things like rhubarb which
you know if you ate raw rhubarb would
not be good for you you know the same
thing with cassava we have engaged with
nature to transform all these things
that are inedible into things that are
edible and in the process you know I
think in every civilization food has
become part of class it's become part of
how people differentiate different
classes from each other and it's also
become a form of entertainment yeah
that's so interesting keep going on this
point yeah
well the more I gave a paper yesterday
about how we can't really understand
modern food unless we think of it as
part of the entertainment industry
cool keep rolling yeah you know because
the if you go back to like some of the
earliest records of humans eating you
find evidence of feast
you know yep getting together and eating
does something to our group that brings
us together in a kind of magic hallway
and creates ties with other people
through a form of magic that's all I can
call it because the our brains basically
run on magic rather than logic I firmly
believe so you know breaking bread with
others exactly exactly and sharing
sharing in the hunt or the gather and
you share because the best place to
store the extra food is in my brothers
or sisters stomach exactly yeah you know
for years archaeologists were digging up
these what they call palaces in Crete as
part of you know centered on this Minoan
civilization and the giant Palace at
Knossos and they were thinking you know
this is where the Lords lived but lately
you know they've excavated some that
were destroyed by earthquakes and it
turns out almost all the rooms were used
to store the pottery used to serve
feasts Wow and that really what these
things were were places where large
groups of people came together and ate
together yep and socialized except if
you think you know when you when you
want to punctuate time when you want to
create a sense of growth in the life yes
you know your birth and your death and
lots of moments your marriage your even
New York divorce kids kids these things
are all marked by foods that we eat and
the same thing like on on the rhythm of
the year yeah
of Valentine's Day and we have Halloween
and we have Thanksgiving coming and
giving and all of these events are you
know on some on some level yeah they're
marketing to us and they're selling us
all kinds of often hideously unhealthy
foods but what we're doing with it is
building community yeah and building
social ties and it's a very human thing
to do and really important because
without it you know we wouldn't have
social identities we would be and we
wouldn't have a moral sense of our duty
to feed other people yeah yeah I like
how you inextricably linked food with
entertainment and socialization I it's
kind of like yeah food socialization
entertaining there's in this trick of
Lea linked and there's a weird fad now
with when you're like in such a
productivity rush in the economic
machinery where you know the robot or
drone delivers you this stuff and then
you just you can get back to you know
working by yourself and playing like
that gamer grub which is stuff in a
pouch that you can just you know you
don't have to take your hand off the off
the controller Soylent yeah exactly yeah
yeah this is and this compare that
process we're talking about to when you
plan to go and source food from a farm
and bring it to your home and have your
friends come and prepare a feast and
invite other friends who also bring
things that they've maybe prepared and
you guys sit down and have a multi hour
night long conversation and feast and
dancing and games and play and music and
drinking and all those other good things
that we recognize it kind of scares me
sometimes that I think we can lose that
because social media is a type of
interaction that never has that material
tie yeah so we don't feel the same sense
of responsibility towards our Facebook
friends
you know the people we communicate with
electronically unless we have some basis
with them of breaking bread as you said
you know the what is some the most basic
human relationship what with our mothers
when we're born is that she feeds us
exact you know and and it comes from her
but we come from her body you know and
what could be a better illustration of
how essential food is to any kind of
social relationship so it's taken a long
time I have to say archeology I started
my career as an archaeologist and I read
an archaeologist but I've always had
this kind of love-hate relationship with
them because instead of thinking about
food
they were like thinking about artifacts
and diet so when you work work on an
archaeological project this is the way
it was what I was doing it the stone
tools go to one person the ground stone
like the monos and MCDOT days that goes
to another person the pottery goes to
the pottery specialist the pollen person
does the pollen analysis you know your f
no botanist or paleobotanist does the
the little remains of seeds and stems
and things that you get from from the
ground and your and your zoo person
takes all the animal bones and and your
human skeletal person takes all the
skeletons and all of those things are
centrally related to the production and
consumption of food the tools the
cooking all those activities but by
taking all the artifacts and sending
them off to separate specialists who do
their own little thing you are getting
lots of information back but it wasn't
information about
food and cooking in social life it was
like a list of the things that people
that appeared in people's diets and
maybe some indication of how it was
produced but you know I remember digging
up a bowl that had been smashed in a
garbage pit and it was full of empty
snail shells what the snails went to one
person to be analyzed and the pot went
to the ceramics person and they're
interested in you know how the pottery
was traded and only in the last 20 years
of they've been interested in what it
was used for yeah so it was always the
focus was on the pot it's like you know
understanding American culture by
looking at containers mm-hmm without
ever paying attention to the stuff
that's in the container soup you know
tamales tortillas so many different
variations and we're like seeing this
absolute revolution in archaeology as
people start to recognize that it's
important you know the way that people
use the food I just saw paper this
afternoon that was really about the
distribution of the of the clay Kamal's
which is what people in Mesoamerica used
to make tortillas yes tortillas weren't
invented until like that eleventh or
twelfth century AD and it turns out that
they were closely associated with one
neighborhood at a particular
archaeological site so some people were
eating tortillas every day and other
people living there were probably eating
mush or you know making tamales or
something else that suggests that there
was some real to different groups of
people living there and it doesn't look
like it was a class issue it looks more
like it was cultural identity you know
these this group of people living in one
neighborhood in another room
people living in another neighborhood
and the technology has just taken off so
we can now look at like trace elements
and bones and help where the person was
born so you can look at skeletons in
graveyards and you could say all the
women were born somewhere else and all
the men were born here which means that
they were marrying people from other
communities and exogamy that tells you
something about their culture yeah which
probably meant that the mothers-in-law
and the and the daughters-in-law were
you know from ethnographic information
we know that's what happens when there's
exogamy and the kit and there's a
kitchen so you know we can tell what
people ate we can tell how much seafood
they were getting in their diet from
looking at different isotope signatures
in the bone Wow
we can now get residue from the edges of
stone tools so we can tell what they
were cutting with it yeah that's crazy
right because like the fat from an
animal actually bonds with the silica in
in the tool and we now can get residue
out of pots and we can say oh they were
drinking cacao out of these pots so now
when we see a particular shape of pot we
can say yeah that's a cacao drinking
vessel yeah and they're that shape
because it was foamy and they didn't
want it to overflow they liked the foam
on top yeah so you know suddenly were
they're turning the tools around and
using these incredible new techniques to
get so much more information than we
ever had before and to think about how
people created social life yes you know
wow this is so important this was one of
the earliest and most important
interventions were these tools that we
used to do things like carry with
a bowl of sorts whether it be like a
water like liquid or food around on our
head or however to the next I mean this
is to be able to analyze that or like
these tools like you said like a knife
and what was that knife cutting right
were those sharp edges cutting you know
what were they actually how can we
analyze these artifacts to know what the
food and the liquids were that were
being used cuz that's gonna give us a
super better understanding of the
culture and like I mean we were just
talking about the importance of food in
today's world well food when you didn't
have computers and all these other
technological devices food was you know
you would spend so much more time on
food and the sourcing and the
preparation and the socialization yeah I
think it also you know I've taught a
couple of courses on famine and in
poverty and I think as archaeology
progresses and we're gonna find out that
there's a close relationship between
politics and hunger yeah
and this is something on art I ascend
Indian economist said years ago and that
is that you know you don't get famine
until you have States and capitalism and
because you know if it's a lack of money
that makes people hungry not a lack of
food so if you watch TV listen to people
talking about famine and hunger and
solving the problem of poor people
so we can we'll grow more food right
that's not the problem the problem is
that they don't have the money to buy
the food and they can't produce it
themselves so I think what archaeology
is going to be able to show us is what
kinds of things produce such a radical
kind of inequality that some people are
willing to stand around eating while
other people in front of them are dying
of starvation
yeah and that's a kind of you know
knowledge that we really really really
need because we've had some really
horrific examples in the last century
you know 50 million maybe died in the
Great Leap Forward in China we didn't
even know about it at the time they're
still trying to keep it quiet but you
know why do we have hungry people in the
most in the richest country in the world
it's just inexplicable how can it still
be that 50 percent of people on the
planet still earn less than two dollars
and 50 cents a day which is what we
purchased that's how much money we use
for a cup of coffee and at the store and
then and then how can it be that in the
days of our history as well that it was
that you could have these massive
massive feasts with very specific social
elites and how we would still even just
like in the past just like today how can
we still allow it that how what is it is
it is it the feelings going back to it
is that the feelings of the deepest
interconnectedness that we can feel as
humans and as a species of deepest
unconditional love that then make it so
that we don't allow that is it the lack
of those deepest principles of
understanding that then make it that we
allow such an equality with food and
nutrition you know this question is
something that I've been thinking about
pretty much every day all my life and
you know I think the tragedy is that
capitalism and market capitalism teaches
us that it's up to us as individuals so
I remember my parents saying you know
don't waste food there's children
starving and
well there's no connection between what
I was eating and you know starving
children in India starving children in
India was not a problem I'm ever going
to be able to solve by my own individual
action and yes we have to be aware of
the way our own consumption affects
other people
but these are the kinds of problems that
we solve politically collectively
they're not things that we can solve by
it's like climate change you know I can
drive an electric car can bicycle but
that's not going to solve the problem we
need structural changes that make cities
bikable for example or that make it
possible to charge your electric car
without searching for two hours and you
know those structural changes they
ultimately have to come from people
putting political pressure on
governments because that's the way we
run things now you know so it means
organize you know don't just try to
change your own you can't change the
world by changing you know what you eat
every day and and I know we need to be
mindful but capitalism teaches us to
just by you know by the right stuff if I
could just buy the right stuff and you
can't buy your way out of this you know
it really requires action and a much
larger scale it feels like it's all it's
on that yes if we took a look at again
that hierarchy of power and we aim to
enlighten government leaders corporate
leaders billionaires etc but also
enlighten those at the grassroots level
and try and figure out what the most
optical you get had that parallax the
parallax of designing the protocols that
that that create that flourishing I mean
that being the priority I mean they're
really children and
optimal education seems in many ways to
be pointing towards a project-based
learning around some of these greatest
challenges that society faces the SDGs
and much more
and just prioritizing also enlightenment
and spiritual actualization bring your
unique gifts forth redesigning that
social fabric I mean this has been so
interesting going back and forth about
consumer culture about food you have
great questions
you're really great thank you yeah it's
a it's the game of tennis you know and
we stand on the shoulders of giants
before us that make it absolutely yeah
but you know the ability to bring ideas
out and articulate them is not that
common you know it's it's a skill and
it's hard to train people to do that but
you know especially the art of listening
is something that we have a real hard
time with these days yeah so thank you
yeah you're you're so welcome I have it
I have one last question for you though
look at asking on the show what do you
think is most beautiful
since I was 19 years old I've been
fascinated by Japanese woodblock print
art I got about 600 of them now it's the
only art form I know where the prices
consistently gone down over the last 40
years but there's what I when I get out
of those prints it's just a radically
different way of seeing things
you know they don't use the same rules
of perspective they use different
conventions for faces and hands and arms
and postures but it was a very popular
art form it wasn't like high art these
are things people bought for pennies you
know to decorate the walls in there and
paste them to the walls in their houses
so you know to me that's always been as
far as human created art a way of
understanding another culture and
another time that really saw things in a
radically different way and if you can
see the beauty in that you can
understand something about the way they
saw the world and understood their place
in it
and particularly I collect prints that
show women doing violent things with
weapons usually interesting because
again we tend to think of Japanese
society today as very rigidly sexist but
that's something that they largely
adopted that because that's what they
thought the West was like and you know
before the before the 1850s before Perry
and his black ships women trained with
weapons and not fake weapons either they
trained with you know sharp ones and
theirs and the Japanese history is
filled with women who have tremendous
agency and tremendous martial skills who
are
kind of remembered as historical figures
yeah that said I have always been
fascinated by seeing the world from
above and like satellite photos yes
drones you know understanding nature by
seeing those the patterns that nature
forms that are you can see them from the
ground but seeing them from from above
and from the air I always find just
fascinating really interesting yeah
that's a great set of you you I love it
I love it thank you again so much for
coming on the program yeah I really
enjoyed it thank you thank you thanks
everyone for tuning in we greatly
appreciate it we'd love to hear your
thoughts in the comments below on the
episode on all these great things that
Rick was teaching us let us know your
thoughts about consumer culture beauty
pageants food history food archeology
all of these different fields we'd love
to hear your thoughts on them check out
the links in the bio below to all of
Rick's books you can find the book link
there you can also find open ant org for
the open anthropology foundation and
Institute you can find that there if you
can please do support the funding of
that we would love to better understand
how our culture I would take paypal we
take things out I love it links in the
bio below and also do support the
American anthropology Association you
can find their links in the bio blow you
can support them on Twitter as well
we'll follow him there and also support
the artists the entrepreneurs the
spiritual leaders the organizations
around the world in your communities
that you believe and support them and
help them grow you can support
simulation our show so you can do doing
cool things like coming on site to great
conferences and summits and interviewing
their leaders you can find our Pay Pal
patreon cryptocurrency design cool merch
you get paid all those links in the bio
below and go and build the future
everyone manifest your dreams into the
world we love you very much thank you
for tuning in and we will see you soon
[Music]
you
[Music]
well that was intense that was really
intense yeah thank you thank you that
was really great it's it's it's
beautiful to be able to take what is
someone's spirit over decades of
understanding reality and then help it
shine and be unleashed
it's a rare skill and and you got it
you